let's talk about the best food or foods
for your eyes now one of the most
important structures in your eye is
called the retina okay now the retina is
Optical tissue it's in the back part of
the eyeball it's not just a small part
it makes up the good portion of the back
part of your eye
then we have a smaller section of that
that's called the macula now maybe
you've heard of the macula as in macular
degeneration as you get older but the
macula is a small section of retinal
tissue and macula comes from the Latin
word which means spot and Lucia means
yellow so it's like a yellow spot
because you have carotenoids in that
area which are it's kind of like a
pigment that is photosensitive so it it
responds to light now the retina is like
um film in your camera there's a lot of
different receptors it picks up
information and it sends it into the
brain via the optic nerve which by the
way has like 1.7 million nerves that are
traveling through that optic nerve which
carries a crazy amount of information
into your brain and so the retina has
different
um cells they're called rods cones and
then you have other cells too which I'm
not going to get into that relate a
information to the internal clock which
is called that Supra chiasmatic nucleus
that is your internal clock and that
clock is regulated by light and darkness
via your eyeball and so you have rods
and cones the rods help you see in kind
of dim light and also they're
responsible for the peripheral vision
versus the cones are more central vision
and they respond in light and allow you
to see finer details and the retina has
like 10 different layers of things going
on so it's it's it's a super highly
complex tissue so the most important
nutrient or the retina
is something called DHA Okay that's an
omega-3 fatty acid now there's also EPA
as a part of that but I'm going to focus
more on the DHA so DHA is in a fat it's
an omega-3 fat that is in pretty much
all your cells it's in the membranes it
helps make the membranes fluid and it
has many different functions it's an
anti-inflammatory but it only makes up
between one and five percent of your
cell membranes
whereas the retina it makes up between
50 and 60 percent it also allows you to
regenerate uh certain pigments in your
eye to allow you to convert information
into your brain its main job is to help
the retina respond to light it's also
very protective against macular
degeneration it's anti-inflammatory and
it inhibits um a negative or pathogenic
form of angiogenesis which is the
formation of new blood vessels because
you don't want to overgrowth of extra
blood vessels that are gonna affect your
vision but DHA is also destroyed by Blue
Light okay and UV light and also omega-6
fatty acids like all those seed oils and
the majority of our Foods also compete
for omega-3 DHA so that can also inhibit
this so DHA is very very important for
the eye right it's probably the most
important nutrient but there's a couple
other things in the retina especially
the macula part of the retina that also
protect the eye against UV radiation as
well as blue light and these are called
carotenoids and there's three very
specific ones lutein zeaxanthin and
another thing called mesozo zeaxanthin
and so the two most important nutrients
in the eye
our DHA and these carotenoids now the
question is what kind of foods make up
these important nutrients you're going
to find the best source in oily
cold water fish as in tuna like
especially Bluefin Bluefin has like five
times the amount of DHA than other types
of tuna but you also have salmon Herring
Cod Liver cod liver oil oysters sardines
and grass-fed beef now of course there's
also DHA in egg yolks and a lot more in
the pasture-raised organic eggs now
there's also precursors to this DHA that
turn into DHA a very small amount but
they still are precursors it's called
ala
and you would find these in walnuts chia
seed and flaxseed so those are the foods
primarily for DHA now what about these
carotenoids you can get them in dark
leafy green vegetable like kale and
salads Etc but they're also present in
egg yolks just as DHA is present in egg
yolks and you can find these carotenoids
in grass-fed beef I participated in a
study that evaluated grass-fed beef
versus grain-fed beef and apparently my
cows had three times the amount of
phytonutrients then other farms in the
United States probably because of the
mixture of plants that my cows can eat
they don't just eat a specific type of
grass there's all sorts of weeds that
they eat so I've talked about that in a
different video which I'll list down
below but a certain zeaxanthin is called
mesozo zeaxanthin is also found in
shrimp fish and of course those egg
yolks so out of all the foods that you
can eat those foods that I just
mentioned they're going to be the best
for protecting the eyes and of course
it's also important to mention the
opposing part of this which is avoiding
omega-6 fatty acids which is really
difficult because it's in all of our
Foods as well as high levels of sugar
which destroy the eyes and create all
the oxidation and the free radical
damage that increases the need for the
carotenoids and DHA and for more
information on that topic you should
probably watch this video right here